good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday it is
gloomy and dark here in new york but
that can't stop me from being annoying
and in a good mood
that's true uh the hurricane is on its
way here it's
supposed to make landfall today is it
true yes so it's going to be a stormy
day
here in new york city and so i hope
everyone is prepared and staying safe
totally all along the eastern seaboard
all along the western
fly he probably thinks it's a real plant
oh my god dead that's so cute
i'll leave them um yeah hope everyone
lives i hope everyone's having a
fabulous day staying safe wherever they
are we have a fabulous show for you guys
today
um kind of short because you know
there's no tv on last night even though
there's a lot to talk about today so
much ellen drama i can't i've been
thinking about it a lot you know it's
been getting to me
it has been yeah do you feel the same
way that you felt last time we spoke
about it what did i say last time
i mean well i feel conflicted because
right as a real outspoken advocate
against cancer culture
um i do feel bad i do but it's hard to
feel bad for someone like when they're
just
so rich and successful do you know what
i mean like it always canceled culture
feels
sad to me when it's like someone on the
rise or like i don't know
because you're a success private person
right like your success gets
away from you you know so i don't know
i'm feeling very conflicted we'll get
into it because like they've launched
their own campaign and it's so weird
um as well as some other stories lots of
bachelor drama
and things of that nature yeah tho is
here being
p-r-e-s-h as usual he got a haircut
and he's just putting on his best foot
forward
for this new chapter in his career yeah
i think we should address
you know some of the controversy from
yesterday's episode okay i got
you know a lot of feedback and people
love to give you feedback even when you
know you don't ask
and a lot of people said that i um like
there was some tension between us
yesterday
and then i got a lot of questions being
like you and jackie like fight ever
before the show and like honestly no
we're too tired we're too tired and to
those who who maybe didn't get in on the
joke
we were totally kidding yesterday and
sorry if we made you feel weird but
there was no weirdness i'm consuming the
tension the only time i could have
pinpointed possible
tension in the episode yesterday was
when we were talking about tiechio and
magnolia and what magnolia has meant to
him and we were just
speculating on how he might feel about
the situation yes you've spoken to him
but
i'm very in touch with him emotionally
no but also like now i'm talking like
real not
not dog language i'm gonna talk human
like we were joking
right because claudia didn't speak to
theo right no
that was not happening unfortunately i
wish
that's the frustrating thing about being
a dog owner it's like you put so much
time energy and love into this person
and
and growing with them but at some point
they just stopped growing because like
at least a kid like
will talk to you and tell you how much
they love you i will never truly know
how much you know
you know i will never i i can speculate
for sure yeah
but i will never truly know you'll never
truly know but but you do know and i'm
so glad he's back here at work
definitely
doing meaningful work helps him and his
mental health
and it's gonna help him be the best
cousin he can be and the best doctor so
helping
theo helps the world do you know 100
which is so important the world is so
important
it's so important so it's going to be a
great show because we have the spirit
of the theo here the spirit of the thou
that you pronounced i thought you
pronounced spirit weird for a second but
you got it right the second time yeah i
i learned linguistics from my sister
snitch
you know i took a linguistics class in
college and it was the only class i
failed
yeah i took it with olivia because like
we were both in college for
one year together when she was
graduating i had just gotten there and
we needed like a general requirement
class we thought it'd be fun to take a
class together and olivia just like
chose one world of linguistic
linguistics of the world and it was
legitimately the hardest class i'd ever
taken
and me and olivia both did terribly but
olivia i think got like a c but she was
the one graduating and if you fail you
don't get the credits right
so i was happy to take the f and in
order to get the f
off your transcript you have to take it
again and i'm like abso [ __ ] lutely
not i
i'm not going to like grad school or
anything so i don't give a [ __ ] about my
transcript
and i never returned sometimes it has to
be done
it was a traumatizing class so everyone
was having a really hard time there was
a girl in there
it sounds it sounds interesting but
definitely hard because even learning
one language is hard so to learn about a
bevy of languages
and it the interesting part which i hear
was just not at all
i was literally like learning i didn't
even i honestly i can't even tell you
what the class was about because i did
not do one piece of homework or barely
showed up
i mean so of course it was hard for you
you know like olivia who's really smart
and like did the bare minimum like
really couldn't get it either and there
was a girl in the class who was a senior
who had a job at jp morgan and i
remember after the final i saw her
crying because she like knew she failed
and they keep track of your gpa when you
get those jobs and she like thought she
was gonna lose her job i don't know
whatever happened to her but i hope
she's okay and successful
i'm sure she's okay yeah so that's why i
never worked at j.p morgan too much
stress
oh my god our oh sorry our hair bomb is
in the way we just like to do a little
mat before the show
i love a hair bomb what would you call
that a shellac it's a
gem pomade palm tree yeah okay
cool cool okay i think we can get right
into it because we've got a lot to
discuss today
and we have nothing to discuss right now
not that much happened for me yesterday
personally oh i actually recorded the
bachelor happy hour podcast which was
fabulous like you know i love to see
rachel lindsay it was on zoom but becca
i couldn't see her she was like in
bad wi-fi so i couldn't see her but i
could hear her and it was just fabulous
it was so funny like me i was literally
dying the whole time like i don't even
know if we spoke about the bachelor
because
we were talking so much you know rachel
and she came to my show in dallas yes
and we had such a good time and she came
with raven and alexis and i do
think that um like that was the last
time her and raven like really ever hung
out
based on the records and the timeline it
it stands that that is the case but it
was an iconic night besides for that and
like we all went out afterwards but
rachel was telling me how she'd
literally gone to a fight at my show
because like she was being so loud and
like all these toasters around here were
telling her to shut up
and it was just such a funny episode i
don't know when it comes out but i'll
let you guys know it was just fabulous
fabulous fabulous
great well that's a perfect segue into
our first story which is one of the big
stories of the day so without further
ado it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite
out of your morning toast and that's
true and just to remind you that today's
episode is brought to you by our patreon
channel
what is patreon you ask it is our
subscription service so if you go to
patreon.comtoast
if you love the morning toast and you
need more you know in august we're going
to weekly episodes but we will still be
releasing our patreon episodes
which are five extra episodes per month
their audio or video we've been doing a
lot of vlogs recently especially in the
queue
for 7.99 you get access to those five
episodes per month and then you also get
access
to the entire backlog of like over 200
episodes that we've been doing since we
started our patreon channel
and you also get access to our facebook
group for patreon members which is the
toast after dark it is our last
remaining facebook group it is the
truly a safe place on the internet and
it's fabulous and
you can only get that if you sign up so
patreon.com slash your morning toast
7.99 great way to get more content and
to support your favorite show
thanks sign on get premium content no
we're still we're sorry we're not done
theo so yeah we're still working get
down get down
okay first story maybe let's get into
the tropes good morning millennials
theo sit down okay first story
tasha adams is replacing claire crawley
on the bachelorette after finding love
early on
sources tell e news claire colley is
being replaced by bachelor and paradise
alum tasha adams on the upcoming season
of the bachelorette
which began filming earlier this month
as if a quarantine season of the
bachelorette wasn't interesting enough
there's a brand new leading lady to pass
out roses
claire crawley is being replaced by
tasha multiple sources tell e-news
quote the producers have told her that
the season will still lead with claire
and her short-lived journey
and will show claire falling in love
with one of her suitors claire will then
conclude her journey and announce that
tasia is the lead
the shocking update comes just weeks
after production officially began on the
18th season of the abc dating
competition series
unlike past seasons where contestants
travel around the world claire and the
contestants were to remain
isolated at a palm springs california
resort she's louise it's hot up there
right now
for the entire duration of filming it's
bachelor in paradise
maybe that's why she wants to leave so
early because she's [ __ ] hot a
whopping 42 men were announced as
contestants presumably because
alternates were needed if any tested
positive for covid
got it so from we heard
the beginnings of this this weekend we
didn't report on it yesterday because it
was still spoiler news and
it's still reality steve like it's not
mainstream yeah and i think you know
we're in no spoiler zone so that's not
something that we were going to discuss
but now that it's you know
going to be on the cover of life and
style weekly this week
we can talk about it so what it seems
like is claire fell in love early on
with one
of her suitors which i think happens for
pretty much everyone
so there is um a lot of speculation i
know the contestant's name i won't say
it because it's just
not that it matters um don't say it i'm
not but there's a lot of speculation
that they were in contact
and communicating way before just given
how this played out which
that makes so much sense she had like
four months where she knew who was going
on her season she's
bored in the house in the house board
she could have started her
season virtually early yeah honestly
like
i don't know i'm kind of annoyed by this
i mean i'm not annoyed because what we
got was tasha which
should have been tasha from the
beginning and we have said on the show
and we literally asked her when she was
on our show like
she is she literally was the
bachelorette of bachelor in paradise
like she was writing her own love
rhombus between a million guys and
that's like the result is great but i
just want to talk about like what claire
did because to be honest like
i find this really like disrespectful a
hundred percent like
i this sean booth wanted to wait this
article
is making it seem like this is such a
romantic and exciting thing and you know
what ultimately it
is because tasha is everything of the
sword and so i'm happy with
what we got but let's talk about how we
got here because
everyone falls in love so early on in
their season especially
the women they know they give their
first impression rose to the person who
they wind up married to
like they go through the emotions of
falling in love you think jojo wanted to
be with robbie final too
no not not only that like at a certain
point like everyone olivia kiriti said
this stuff she's like
when we were on our season like we were
in the airport and stuff we weren't
filming everyone knew that lauren was
winning like
it was just clear so these two people
are in love you think everyone doesn't
want to quit and run away like that's
not how it works and i don't know
i feel like this is such a um like a
slap in the face not that i like give a
[ __ ] about abc or like production but
like
all the lengths they had to go to to
like make this happen during covid like
took over a hotel made a basically a
bubble got all these guys tested all
these guys like
it's so much work just for her like one
week or two weeks in to be like oh i
changed my mind like
sorry that's really not how it works and
i get that you love someone but like
this is what you signed up for
and to be honest it really makes me feel
like she was undeserving of the job
yeah i agree because it is a job as much
as it's a it's a privilege
and it's so amazing amazing and cool
like it's also
a job a lot of people have jobs
surrounding it and at a certain point
you become an actress on the show you're
not in love
with 25 guys trying to figure out which
one you love the most like you
fall for one maybe two people and then
you fake your way through the rest of it
of course because it's tv
because it's tv and that's what we
signed up to see and i think that her
we'll see the way it goes down but from
what i got from snatchler
who is you know close to to these sorts
of issues she said that claire refused
to fail that she
locked herself in her room and that she
was done and
to me that's just like how old are you
you're supposed to be one of the older
contestants you're acting like a 19 year
old like
honestly this leaves such a bad taste in
my mouth for claire like i'm really i
really
wasn't now that it's over like i really
wasn't that interested in watching her
season anyway i was actually wasn't
going to watch this season and now i'm
going to
so um maybe somewhere somehow like
someone did this intentionally
no i don't think so i'm just like i'm
really disappointed and like the lack
not that i i can't explain like i don't
care like that abc
and all these producers who like
literally spend their days like editing
girls to look bad like
i really don't care that like they you
know lost time and money but what but
like
it's just disrespectful to the
institution that gave you an opportunity
when honestly like you didn't really
deserve it you haven't been on the
bachelor in 10 years you know
yeah i'm just i'm i'm a little annoyed
but i really can't be that annoyed
because what we got
and what we ended up with is so fabulous
and it just proves that it should have
been tation she was overlooked
and this is what happens when you
overlook someone are you happy
yeah and then also according to the
snatcher they're bringing in
new guys for tasha some of the guys who
were announced as claire's first
batch of guys but that were like really
young and then
covet happened and so they brought in
new guys and so some of those
original guys will be coming in for
tasha and i hope she gets the full
boat of suit like i don't they can't
half-ass any of this i don't want to see
her in
15 contestants i want limousines i want
the whole
full monty for her and it kind of sucks
that like
she is getting guys who are
cast for claire because you know they
cast differently for every person based
on age
like you know what i mean sort of yeah
and so i don't know
i just i really hope she doesn't get
shafted yeah i that's what i'm hoping to
and i also it goes without saying
now claire must marry this man and be
with him for five years
children grandchildren the whole nine
yards the whole nine yards if they're
not living together in a nursing home
when they're 90 like i
am i'm protesting like i'm upset it's
just
i don't know something about this really
rubbed me the wrong way it's like
how many bachelor bachelorettes i think
we're going on like 30 now who have been
the leads like
you think you're special like everyone
falls in love like it's hard and you see
them struggling with it
right especially as it gets like closer
and it's like five people four people
yeah that's literally what you signed up
for and if you can't handle it then
maybe you shouldn't have signed up for
it that is the literal show and yes and
sometimes people do break down that
fourth wall even like colton ending his
season to go be with cassie but like
he wrote it out till the final three
yeah
she was had like 40 guys left and she
still decided like
i don't know i'm just i'm not i'm not
happy with her i'm not gonna lie
no i'm not happy with her either but i'm
like living for the tea and i'm living
for tasia so like it's
it's double edge you know i'm like mad
like i'm not really that mad no i agree
like i just i feel like the point needs
to be made but like yeah right
when i go move on with my day like i'm
excited about the new season of the
bachelor i absolutely love tasha i think
she will make a sensational bachelorette
so
like everything fabulous and inside and
out and i'm so excited she
she really was the bachelorette of
paradise even though nicole thought it
was her
truly it was tasha and so she ready
she's got the chops
she's stunning she's smart she's funny
she's
literally the most beautiful woman i've
ever seen in my life like she's going to
be great and it's no it's honestly going
to be a great season and i'm probably
more excited
and then after this year we will have
had three black leads which is a major
improvement from the one
so it's good it's good but i just wanted
to point out like the hypocrisy and the
lack of respect
sorry yeah you know what in a lot of
ways and very similar to monica geller
like i just
i'm a stickler for the rules you know
and like i just think they're there for
a reason you know and if you can't
follow them you know that's how i feel
if you can't follow them like don't play
i completely agree
don't hate the player hate the game no
out of the game oh yeah but i'm hating
the player
no no she she was hating the players but
she shouldn't have been in the game
she was ill-equipped for the game no she
had no proper training she had no
understanding of the rules and she had
no business being on the field no no she
was
not trained no not at all okay should we
keep the metaphor going
we i mean we could we could we always
could but we won't
we're striking out for now okay next
story is a series of stories in the saga
that is the ellen degeneres maybe
cancellation and i don't want to call it
there's okay here's where it's dicey and
i don't want to call it a cancellation
because when you get canceled as a
regular
first of all there's a level of
celebrity where you are uncancelable
ellen's there ellen is there but there's
also when a person gets canceled whether
it's a digital influencer whether it's
someone
just at their job like people get
canceled in everyday life and it's
it's about all of the powers that be
turning on you
and that's not what's happening to ellen
her she still has her show no
advertiser has said we're not going to
work with ellen anymore it's every
it's it's the people on the ground who
are just have like their little voices
it's not necessarily your
average cancellation where it's a few
people who decide that you don't deserve
a livelihood anymore that's
very true and an incredible
comparison to make where it's like for
for influencers or like reality stars so
let's take like sassy and kristen for
example like
literally bravo their podcast networks
like the powers that be
people in charge decided they were
effectively canceled and then brands
that work with them
right and so then everyone followed suit
like once bravo canceled them it was
like
you're done yeah um but that's true like
warner brothers is
you know warner media has this like fake
investigating investigation
going on but at the end of the day like
really the people who are like upset
with ellen and wanting
are people who have been hurt by her
yeah or people who just watch her show
like people who just know her like
i don't have a network i'm not gonna
pull ellen for my show i'm just like
disappointed in her actions
yeah but also the people who have been
the loudest right now are people who
have been on her show
and have had negative experiences which
there are
a lot right so i just want to make that
distinction because
i'm anti-cancer culture and honestly i
think we'll go through all of this
i think ultimately my opinion is going
to be that ellen should
keep her show um but it's just an
interesting conversation being had
because she's so powerful and it
all really started as sort of these
whispers you know it was like a
grassroots
movement yeah so first up porsche de
rossi is breaking her silence on the
ellen scandal
she is quote standing by her wife amid
reports of the talk show host alleged
bad behavior behind the scenes
quote to all of our fans dota dot we see
you thank you for your support she
captioned a quote that said
i stand by ellen in the hosts signature
white and baby blue show colors
when you posted this yesterday i was
like we stand by ellen
it looked like i posted that we said but
no i was just quiet
and he was like oh so you're standing by
ellen oh no
um no we just needed to post that portia
de rossi like broke her silence i
was really shocked that a quote card had
been made and you know
your movement isn't really all that
powerful when the only person posting
about it is your wife like no offense
this is
this was really sad and honestly the
graphic was low level designer like this
looked like it was made out of microsoft
paint
and it was just it made the whole
movement like
so sad yes but an interesting factoid is
that jerry o'connor
also posted it and he's someone who
i i believe i believe no i
i saw it first on jerry o'connell's and
i'm like where did this graphic come
from jerry o'connell didn't make it
and then i searched down the rabbit hole
that portia had made it
and i was very shocked to find that
jerry o'connell had posted it because i
agree with you i respect him
and i be like i think he's a good judge
of character we have hung out with him
and he was so funny and so nice and so
like human so it's like i trust his
opinion on housewives therefore i know
that we have like similar just judgments
of people in general
totally he's standing by element it just
makes you stop and think
yes but there are also other celebrities
who are standing by ellen katy perry
released a series of tweets
yes i have that here katy perry defends
ellen amid talk show controversy quote
sending you love and a hug
she said i know i can't speak for anyone
else's experience besides my own but i
want to acknowledge that i've only ever
had positive takeaways for my time with
ellen
and on the ellen show i think we have
all witnessed the light and continual
fight for equality that she has brought
to the world through her platform
for decades see that's true well i think
what katy perry tweeted
just actually validates what other
people are saying because what other
people are saying is like
unless you're jennifer aniston or katy
perry or the kardashians like
you're not ever gonna get a word from
ellen like you're not gonna get respect
you're not gonna get treated nicely
so of course katy perry had a positive
experience she's the one of the biggest
stars in the world like this
tracks with what we already know which
is that ellen
like respects fellow a-listers we never
thought that she didn't but then like
the guy from everybody loves raymond the
tall guy whose name i don't know brad or
something
he was like yeah and nikki tutorials and
corrine olympios like people who are not
a-list like
i know katy perry was trying to help but
in a lot of ways she validated a lot of
people's concerns yeah
i totally agree but she also did bring
up a point it's like everyone
say what you want about ellen by the end
of the day like she is
was the first openly gay woman on
television and she does have all these
really huge accomplishments and
accolades and it's like this is where
canceled culture gets dicey it's like
how do you invalidate that you can't no
you can't
i think yeah i think that people are
struggling with that general question of
do the ends justify the means
i don't know i mean to be honest all
that's coming out
for me isn't what's like most
disappointing what's most disappointing
is her
lack of response and like when she does
respond that letter she released to her
um crew that obviously went public
which literally just threw everyone
under the bus
she did not take responsibility for one
part of it and let's say she was telling
the truth like the three producers who
she put in charge andy lassner
ed galvin and someone else i'm sorry i
don't know his name
let's say that these three guys you know
took ellen's name and they made this
rampant culture
with racism sexual harassment toxicity
all this stuff like let's say
ellen was not lying in that memo you are
still responsible like you still have to
take an ounce of accountability because
it's your show with your name
so while i don't even think that that's
the truth the fact that she threw them
under the bus and then still didn't take
any accountability like
what was the point in releasing that
memo right when i first read the memo i
i took it at its face value which is
like i i believed her where it's like
she did not know about any of this you
know this is something like obviously
she feels responsible but like she did
not commit to do it these acts but then
i just saw all this stuff
that was like she knew about all of this
of course and i'm like
stop with the lies stop with the lies
and you know what at the end of the day
like you said it starts from the top and
so just to take yourself out of the
equation completely
in a situation like this is not going to
satiate people's need for
accountability from you and i feel like
whoever is handling this
for palin is handling it's so poorly
between this janky-ass
graphic from porsha and that terrible
letter she sent out to her staff
i just it's like she doesn't want to
turn this around you know
yeah well so then the next part of the
conversation is people are speculating
about who might be in line to replace
ellen yeah an article came out this week
that james corden is in line to replace
her the sun
newspaper reported um despite other
signs that she's not going anywhere
anytime soon
so i want to talk about james gordon who
you think could replace her and also if
you think she's going anywhere anytime
soon if i were a betting woman
and i were putting money on this i would
bet that she is not going anywhere me
neither she has had
literally a long successful career she's
not going out like this i feel like for
her she sees it this is just a bump in
the road and
i think she's just the investigation
will happen
whatever i don't know of any internal
investigation that has ever been so
damning
right towards what they were
investigating also
you know ellen lives in like a
simulation like she lives in
her palace by the sea and i don't think
she really knows like what's going on
and like how big of a story this is
because
she's so famous that like and i'm just
sure she's not reading every article and
every tweet about her
yeah and also it's not so many articles
i feel like it's the tweets
actually i've been seeing a lot of
articles and the washington post did
like a full rundown of how this whole
thing started
and it was fascinating and there were so
many clips like
everyone knows the moments that are
uncomfortable dakota dakota johnson
i saw two clips that like i was shook by
which oh the mariah carey clip
the mariah carey clip where she
basically forced mariah carey to
announce that she was pregnant even
though mariah was having fertility
issues so she was
she was pregnant at the time but she was
hesitant to say
publicly given all that had happened and
ellen made her drink champagne
to be like well if you're not pregnant
have champagne and she like pretend and
she put it down and it turns out that
she actually had a miscarriage after
that so it's like
what are you doing ellen and the second
thing was something more recently
where she played a prank on her audience
like these private citizens who love
ellen who went to her show
where she put them all in a waiting room
and they were all really big fans and
they had free merch and it was like take
one item
and they filmed people who took like two
mugs instead of one and literally she
called out this woman
she put her in l in jail she sat on the
stage
she was like it was so embarrassing and
so awful like this girl took an extra
hat okay like it said ellen on it for
her sister
who loved ellen but couldn't make it to
the taping and ellen was like
well a lot of people sisters couldn't
make it to the taping it was
insane it was so much worse than the
dakota johnson one like i don't know why
the dakota johnson one took off
and not the mariah carey or this one it
was horrible
i have not seen that terrible to me
that is worse than anything because that
is a private citizen
yeah and it's not like she stole all the
hats like if if it was someone who went
in there with a
shopping bag and threw them all in and
didn't leave for other people and was
probably gonna sell them on ebay
okay i mean ellen jail is a little crazy
but fine whatever
to take one extra for your sister and
when like a lot of people took extras
and she literally called out this one
cute woman and it was
it was so sad we need to get that woman
on like the today show you know who i
want to hear from on this
mason ramsay's grandparents yeah they're
honest
and that interview you know a lot of
these interviews are popping up and i'm
surprised that the mason ramsay one has
it because she was
so [ __ ] condescending to him and that
was really like a turning point for me
that was a turning point for me too when
he said his dream was to go to college
and she was like reality wow that's in a
beautiful [ __ ] dream beautiful dream
medicine that's beautiful like that was
that was upsetting like that whole thing
um okay
but the james corden james corden and in
addition to that twitter is also
sounding off about who should replace
ellen they're coming in with all their
suggestions well i don't know if the
james corden thing is true but like to
be honest this is like the same
conversation we have about award shows
like
there is a circle of straight white men
named james
and it's never ending like the
opportunities that they get and like
they're so
and to give ellen's platform which was
really built on like gay pride like just
to give it
to james corden is like what and i like
james corden that's
i actually love him it's it's hard
because i actually think
if the job were an open position he
would be great he would carry like that
joy and love that
that is her legacy publicly
he would carry that on like he's all
about music and and
she's all about dancing and i think he
would actually be a great
fit for the role but it just in terms of
who deserves this opportunity
and like the legacy like of ellen who
like fought so hard
trailblazer just to have it go back to
the status you can't
you can't yeah even though i agree he'd
be sensational
yeah like but also he's great on on his
show and also if he i guess if he did
take over her show
someone that would open his spot on the
late late all right i'll do it i'll
do it so people have a lot of
suggestions for who they think it could
be tiffany haddish
would love it michelle obama oh wow drew
barrymore
she already has a show she's busy but i
guess
it could be that you know her show has
like been in development forever i know
but that's also because we're in a
pandemic oh
true forgot about that um jerry seinfeld
he would literally never do it wake up
work every day
yeah he would never do it i don't like
any of those suggestions to be honest
except
actually tiffany haddish is good she's
funny yeah i mean again like just
because you're funny
doesn't mean you would have a funny show
because part of being a talk show host
is listening
it's so much there are so many skills
that you need to have and we see it all
the time with people who you think would
be perfect for her talk show bethany
meredith vieira kris jenner ugh that was
that didn't get it was heading out
agreed like with the whole set recreated
as her living room like
it was it was too soon we were ready we
didn't
like at that time like right now kris
jenner is a true icon and when you watch
her now she and you're like chris jenner
is my favorite we need more we need more
back then we were just still so caught
up in the girls yeah didn't know what we
had
and i don't think like the country saw
her yet as this like
maternal figure and now it's like we
need that voice
yeah i i feel very strongly about the
fact that chris never got
a fair shot yeah i agree now i'm trying
to think about who could
replace ellen i hadn't given it much
thought kelly clarkson i was just going
to say that but she's doing great
things she's great yeah she seems like
she's doing really well okay so let us
know
what you think what do you think yeah
sound off in the comments yeah
um next story some sweet young
relationship news jojo siwa introduces
her quote
amazing new boyfriend in a must-see tick
tock
i did see it the teenage internet
sensation announced she's in a
relationship
with mark bontempo if mark's last name
sounds familiar it's because he's the
little brother of social media star
madison von tempo don't know her no i
can't say that i do no
taking to tick-tock over the weekend
jojo confirmed the news about her
boyfriend with a cute video quote meet
mark she captioned her post along with a
smiley face
in the short clip the two were dancing
to mozzie's famous
while dressed up in each other's
clothing jojo rocked her boyfriend
skinny jeans a cream-colored sweater
and mark went full out and put on her
signature look
which included the glittery bow
bedazzled jacket
multi-colored skirt tights etc yeah they
did that challenge where everyone like
dresses as their boyfriend their
boyfriend dresses as them but
but theo's parents did it best thank you
i agree follow me on tick tock
that's one of my favorite tick tocks of
all time like watching really turned it
out
ben there's just something so
so beautiful about it something so
dazzling about his performance
yeah no he really is makes for a
beautiful and and confident woman
so confident a little too confident um
back to jojo siwa having a boyfriend
like this is so crazy but
at the end of the day we like there's
who is jojo siwa you know like we think
she's like this
12 year old girl who runs around in bows
and performs songs that literally sound
like theme songs for cartoons
but at the end of the day she's 17. she
has needs yeah and she has a boyfriend
at the end of the day she's 17
taking a bath at the end of a long day
chain smoking
a pack of cigarettes there is a you know
really um unfounded rumor that jojo see
what chain smokes
and you know what if you hear her voice
enough times it
kind of tracks it's not even that
there's any evidence that would make you
believe it but when i first heard it
it's for some it just stuck with me
yeah and that coupled with the fact that
she's shadily like five foot ten
really made me believe it yeah and she
is she's really growing up she's been
posting more
videos of her with her hair down i'm i i
think she's getting to that
you know hannah montana crowley corner
smallmouth hannah montana versus
miley cyrus lizzie mcguire versus hilary
duff like
when can i just be me and
i think she also loves being jojo and i
think she does love the bows and stuff
but you know you can't be on all the
time no but i do think she loves being
a role model seriously for young people
like even if she takes her bows out like
she's going to continue she's not going
to be you know naked on the cover of
and she's not going to call the
paparazzi and then smoke a cigarette in
front of them you know
she do she's not going to do that to the
fans i really think she takes her duty
as a role model very very seriously and
we need role models like that for the
children at any age yes
i totally agree um also we need people
who
want to be role models for sure and we
also need to stop expecting people who
never ask to be role models
to be good role models yes like just
because you have a platform that should
not make you a role model like don't
follow me if you don't want to see me
chain smoking cigarettes you know what i
mean yeah um but back to the jojo siwa
thing i also think
this might be you know something she's
dealing with is like she really is
growing up and maybe she doesn't want to
run around
in a tight ponytail that's gonna give
her a migraine every day with a bow
um but that is so ingrained in her brand
and like she is just churning out
product left right and center she has
like these crazy deals with walmart
she sells she has like her own
lunchables her own juice box like unless
you're really in it you don't know
how wide her network of merch and like
branding is
and she has to continue to be that like
she really does her backpacks her
her clothing she she has to be that girl
even when she doesn't want to be i
understand that and i do think
she will continue to do that but i also
think there are ways for her to evolve
where she doesn't have to like
completely
go the other way and she can sort of
phase out take steps like
even when hannah montana got that
haircut you know it was just like a
whole new
it has a whole new hannah and i feel
like i could even see jojo doing like
half up half down and sort of moving
into the sort of ponies that
ariana grande does and the chic up do a
shin
and maybe the bow gets a little smaller
and maybe then the bow goes here or the
bow goes in the back like
i think it's time if this is what she
wants there are ways where you can
gradually evolve and it doesn't have to
be such a stark contrast for the fans
when they wake up one day and they're
like
where's my jojo no and jojo's like
literally on the cover of vanity fair
wearing nothing but a bed sheet
totally exactly remember when that was
like the craziest thing happening in our
country like we didn't know how good we
had it in 2010 yeah when literally like
billy ray cyrus was under fire for being
on set when anna lewis took a picture of
miley cyrus from the back and like you
could see
literally a centimeter of her butt crack
yeah that was a crazy
crazy time i literally it's like one of
those things where it's like you
remember where you were when like you
saw it i was in the airport
and was on the tv and like it was
literally like the parents of america
were
yeah wait i'm trying to think um i want
to see if i have the timeline right
when that cover was because i feel like
i remember which airport we were in i
think it was like fort lauderdale
uh was it i think we were on vacation as
kids
it was like 2008. it was crazy times
crazy times also um back to something
that you said so beautifully earlier
thank you
i really do think that we need a
docu-series called who is jojo siwa
where she can sort of answer some of
these questions and and in turn
help herself get out of here but i do
think
so much of her success is built on this
mystery like she's this anomaly and
kids like kim kardashian's kids [ __ ]
die for her like
there is this air of mystery around her
that i think adds to the spectacle i do
yeah and maybe like she takes her hair
down and puts on a ball cap and
and and goes and is a normal kid
sometimes
maybe she loves what she does you know
you never know but you know you do
assume that she does eventually want to
grow out of this but maybe she doesn't
yeah i mean
we just assumed that because everybody
who came before her like didn't love
what they did
but maybe she loves what she does that
would be refreshing
and that would really make her the true
role model it's so sad when you love
like the way that i loved han montana
and to know that like she hated her the
whole time it's but no not the whole
time but towards the end
it just it does take away from the joy
from the
magic i agree completely it would be
nice to have like a
a person who loved like the character
that they created for themselves
yeah i mean i love girl with nothing not
to make it about me yeah
okay fifth and final story a little
sports news oh we are so athletic let me
just do my stretches
dwayne the rock johnson and an investor
group
agreed to buy the xfl for 15 million
dollars
that's it a team or the whole league the
whole league you know the xfl itself
football league ben is like all into it
he thinks it's going to be like the next
big thing
right so apparently so does dwayne
johnson the xfl had come back
our husbands even went to a game and
they were planning for like a really big
launch but then
kovit hit and so now dwayne johnson
um has agreed to including with other
investors but he's the biggest
he's the future has agreed to purchase
the xfl for about 15 million dollars
according to a news release issued on
monday that seems so low
the xfl declared chapter 11 bankruptcy
on april 13th and has been seeking a
buyer for the past three months
marketing itself as a made-for-tv
product that could transition
as early as 2021 to a bubble concept
during the coronavirus pandemic
johnson and his investors are planning
are making plans to play next season
um they told espn so this is kind of
exciting i feel like right now
with all of the uncertainty going on in
the sports world this is actually a
perfect time for some
sort of like alternative extreme version
because if it really is made for
television
maybe i don't know how the xfl works
what makes it extreme i just like to
imagine like football players on
trampolines
no no no it's like rough it's like
rugby-ish i think
there's no trampolines no um that's
that's highly entertaining yeah well you
know sometimes life is so weird because
art truly imitates life and dwayne
johnson is on a show on hbo called um
ballers and it's so good first of all
and
ricky who is the guy denzel washington's
son who was in black klansmen he's like
one of the stars
it's such a good show and literally in
the show he's like this
you know hustle make money deals guy who
is a sports agent and tries to bring a
football team to
las vegas so it's like truly and he was
just like trying i don't know what ended
up happening i stopped watching the show
but like he was just like wanting to buy
something really bad
and dwayne johnson made that happen for
spencer you know his character yeah art
is just
mirroring life just like montana yeah
it's beautiful to say it is beautiful to
see so those were the fast five stories
i feel as though you needed to know them
yes they were bad stories yeah i think
so there i mean there was
72 ellen's story yeah there was two
sects of ellen's stories one two
three yeah that's five sorry fabulous
well i feel informed
yeah i feel informed as well oh last
night i watched so now i'm caught up to
yellowstone so now i'm watching
everyone and the new episode was kind of
a meh
actually i i feel like in the beginning
the episodes were so long and so much
would happen i would be like am i still
watching the same episode and then last
night it ended sort of abruptly maybe
they're like running
low on content because of filming and
corona buyers so they're like slicing up
the episodes differently
i just really wish you would watch the
show because i know that you would love
it and like it's a whole other world
okay well my docket did free up because
i finished shameless last night and i
told you that
i started the season and i thought it
was so much better and when i finished
it like i actually was
sobbing it was such a beautiful episode
and
i just i think they should have gotten
rid of emmy rossum years ago she just
took up so much space on the tv and like
so much time
and it's really an ensemble cast i would
say there's like
13 main characters but she was really
like the main main one and the whole
show kind of revolved around her and she
had the worst decision making skills and
it was just so annoying
and now that she's gone it's left room
for the other characters to really like
evolve and you get more character
development
and it's so much better like i think
that it's like it's literally a brand
new show and i hope that people like i
hope they won't end it now that she's
over like i hope it's not on its last
leg
because it was really good and jeremy
allen white is just the man of my dreams
and i love him
um so it was good i also have two
episodes left of the crown and like for
some reason i just can't get myself to
watch them because
i love it so i've done that with like
mostly just shit's creek where i refuse
to let it end
where is season four of the crown what
do you mean when is it coming
oh probably not for a while because like
the way it's so
beautifully and ornately done that
there's a lot of time between seasons
so i do have some free time especially
now with the gap
right in the filming so maybe i'll get
into yellowstone but
um i've just been like living in
shameless for a few days so i need to
get out of it i understand i also
finished um the redheads book last night
and we're recording the episode today
so if you have questions that you want
us to answer about the book email us at
the redheadsbookclub gmail.com we
actually got some amazing questions
the book is really intense and i had i
didn't read up there's a lot of
discussion around the book itself that i
hadn't read up on until i finished the
book because i didn't want any spoilers
and i think like the book itself posted
some like really tough and interesting
questions and then also the
the discussion around the book and the
storytelling
is just really interesting so that's
where i've been and i'm looking forward
to recording the episode today and i'm
looking forward to what snitch's choice
is going to be
if you're ever looking to become a
redhead i would start on a snitch's
choice because
it's it's always a great it's always a
great pick those are our most popular
episodes and you know as they say
it's never too late to join the redheads
it's never too late to join the redheads
and that goes for you as well
okay um but i have to promote my comedy
special so maybe i'll do that after i'll
join the red heads after i promote my
comedy special i mean it wouldn't it
would never be too late because i got
some
um i've been getting some messages from
international toasters who are having a
hard time purchasing on amazon
or itunes i also got a lot of emails
from people who said that they got it
fine but
if you haven't been able to watch it
because you are in canada or australia
or somewhere that you're having a hard
time buying it
on the regular platforms i have a link
to where you can rent or purchase it on
vimeo which is the according to you know
my people
the best place for international
transactions
but again if you haven't even watched my
comedy special you don't know what i'm
talking about i released a comedy
special about a month ago it's called
disgraced queen it's available for
purchase
or rent on itunes apple tv
amazon vimeo tons of places also
if you want to listen to it like you do
listen to this podcast the album is
available on spotify itunes amazon music
all the places where you can listen to
music
it's called disgraced queen and all the
information is on my instagram story
highlight called disgrace queen with
links to everything
that you need in order to purchase
perfection
anything else we need to say before we
wrap this up no i think that's all she
wrote we'll be back tomorrow for
hump day dear toasters etc and a
reminder that this is our last full week
in studio starting next week we are
going to be releasing
weekly episodes every wednesday i want
to address some of the controversy
surrounding weekly episodes
because i i've been seeing i saw like
the most like fake news comment where
someone was like they're going to weekly
episodes like without the addendum that
it's just
for a month for a month four weekly
episodes it's four weekly episodes for a
month while we're on vacation this is
in no way us trying to switch to weekly
episodes
forever like we just want to give you
content while we're on vacation
yeah i also saw some fake news of people
being like we are trash because
we are traveling for a month and i just
again need to put it out there that that
is 100 not true we will all be in a
house quarantined together we are not
flying anywhere
like i can't even deal with the nonsense
with the nonsense like if you're if you
don't listen to the show and it didn't
come from my lips
stop [ __ ] speaking about us because
you don't know anything and you're
annoying as hell
yeah so thank you you have no plans to
go to weekly episodes after our hiatus
it's truly just a break like we this is
our job people like where are you going
i'm like i have to make a living i will
be back in september
yeah we love the show we love doing
daily show we love the set we'll be back
um it's truly just a hiatus just think
of us like the view
yes do you think of us like watch what
happens live everywhere because i like
the jimmies
the jimmy's the jimmy's uh kimmel has
been on hiatus for a mad long time
i mean i hope he's enjoying his his
vacation thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennium morning show
where we deliver the first five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
every weekday on youtube and we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found so that's spotify itunes
stitcher public radio i already cast box
all the places wherever you listen to
podcast find us morning toast leave a
five star view about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are we love you
guys we hope you have a great day and
we'll see you tomorrow
bye goodbye